wir würden also bei einem jetzigen tempo
würden wir ungefähr
ja ich sage mal in sechs wochen schon
jetzt
würden wir tatsächlich eine impfmenge
bekämpft haben das hat sich die impfung
selbst die zahl der neuinfektionen
absenken
das ließe sich lediglich ändern und
sechs wochen können wir nicht warten bis
dahin sind also sehr viele menschen
erkannt sehr viele menschen infiziert
das würde intensiv mit ihm niemals
kompensieren können also diese sechs
wochen
die müssen überbrückt werden wir müssen
irgendwie klarkommen dahin zu kommen
man könnte die also verbreitung der
infektionsketten durch die impfung nur
erreichen wenn man die im strategie
verändern würde und würde nur noch
erstimpfungen für zwölf wochen auf den
abstand zwischen der erstimpfung der
zweite impfung bei moderner und bei und
tag stecken wenn man sich auf die erste
impfungen konzentriert dann kann man
also am anfang doppelt so schnell die
erstimpfung geben weil die zweite
impfung verschoben sind und das würde
tatsächlich auch auf das
infektionsgeschehen wirken macht aber
die stiko zum jetzigen zeitpunkt leider
nicht mit obwohl die wissenschaftlichen
ergebnisse in meiner einschätzung und
auch in der einschätzung viele
epidemiologen virologen dafür sprechen
ich finde das was wir jetzt sehen ist
ein sehr trauriges schauspiel es wird
übermacht fragen diskutiert wie viel
einfluss soll der bund haben also
brauchen lernen des föderalismus reform
soll noch einmal also das gesamte system
bearbeitet denn das
infektionsschutzgesetz geändert werden
dabei brauchen wir als noch ein
schnelles handeln wir müssen jetzt
schnell einen kurzen lockdown bringen
der noch einmal die zahlen in den griff
bekommen in der dritten welle ich später
wir das machen desto länger dauern
die intensivstationen werden voll und
menschen werden sehr schwer krank wir
sind wirklich am vorabend haben wir
richtig schweren infektionswelle
und da brauchen wir nicht also die rede
über politik und keine profilierungs
kämpfe sondern es muss er wirklich
politik gemacht werden müssen schnell
die regeln für den walk down machten wir
sind bild und wir liefert dir deine news
auf youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren